what should the joe or jill filmmaker
who's brand new
who wants to know about a particular
film festival do should they find out
who some of the alumni are
find those filmmakers websites and then
just shoot him a quick email and what
should that email say
um newbie filmmakers can write to the
filmmakers that have been other
festivals their best about it is to go
to the
festivals website look at the kinds of
films that have played at that festival
see if they're in the same species as
their own movie if they're all
star vehicles that came out of sundance
they're probably not going to play your
little film if they're all local alabama
films and you're not a local alabama
film
they're probably not going to play your
film if they play mostly foreign films
they play
social consciousness movies and your
films of morrow movie you know make sure
you fit the program
then yeah if you want to know about it
i've done this is you write to
filmmakers
that have been at that this is actually
a good idea for anything
talking to a distributor talking to a
film rep
look on their website and see who's
played their festival who they
represented or who've been distributed
by that distributor whoever it is
and write to those filmmakers because
nine times out of ten they'll write back
to you
and uh just say hey you know um um
you know my name is you know my name is
paul osborne i made this phone call
favor
um we're considering submitting to the
indie memphis film festival
we see you we saw you play there last
year if you wouldn't mind letting us
know
whether it's worth our time it looks
like a good festival but sometimes you
can't tell from a website what were your
impressions was a good bad
don't do it through the festival or
through the don't ask them who can i
talk to
go to their website and write them
independently because obviously you want
to get
a real answer um 11 times out of 10 and
unless you're
writing to this the studio film that was
there you know the opening night studio
film if you're writing to a film
that's around the same again in the same
species as your movie
they'll probably write back to you and
they'll be honest because
filmmakers tend to like to help other
filmmakers you know i find it's much
more of a brotherhood
than than than maybe i think
maybe i think sometimes distributors
wish it was they wish we would fight it
out but i think
it's i mean i like to help other
filmmakers you know